just imagine for a second on the beach
enjoying precious time with your family
and friends and all the while you're
making money doing nothing but enjoying
life you make the most money while you
sleep this is no dream and in the next
few minutes this will become your
reality
I think that there's an enormous massive
misunderstanding that there are almost
zero people that have pulled off
substantial success without putting in
real time and effort
I think that when people say hey let's
do passive income they going to expand
City USA but please make sure that your
passive income has practicality to it
because all the people that have tried
to create systems and automate their
cash there's been a very small
percentage of people that have been able
to lay on the beach while they collect
money on the Internet a lot of that
stuff is completely ludicrous this video
is highly confidential and private
invitation only
I'm about to reveal to you a very
powerful and 100% automated online cash
machine that will allow you to make
enough money so you to get on a piece of
paradise all from using my secret cash
machine system it's a hedge it's a video
that hedges all the fast quick like I'm
gonna make it in a minute to talk about
the thing that I think is most
tried-and-true I've been working
everyday hard and smart for 20 years and
those are the people that when I look
around the world the people that I meet
at business meetings the 50 60 70 80 90
year olds that I asked him how did you
make it happen it was putting in the
work
there is no quick cure put in the work
use your talents against the work that's
how the outcome happens now we all have
different ambitions and goals do I think
that it's easier to create $60,000 a
year in passive income on the internet
today I sure do and if that's what your
goal and ambition is that's more
practical than millions and I get it and
then this is why I'm making this video
because there are 17 billion videos on
YouTube right now telling you how
they're gonna make you a ton of money in
this 90 day process a millions of
dollars in passive income on the
internet smoking [ __ ] weed in Jamaica
while it just keeps coming in it's just
not as real as you think partner right
because that's what everybody thinks it
is like it's that's not real [ __ ] show
me cuz I'll show you a billion people
that like have won through hard work
show me show me this magical person
because I'll show you somebody who sells
you that dream but isn't actually doing
it Wow that I'll show you you want me to
hire some models for the afternoon and
get a boat and go to some sunny [ __ ]
place and be like this is a
I'll show you that you want me to show
you the people on Instagram who go take
all the money they own in the world in
hundred-dollar forms in the bank and
throw it on a bed and take a picture and
then put it back in their bank I'll show
you that I'll show you the front of this
passive income dream of the Internet
sorry
you